regarding that game last night there was
so much hype all right it's it was the
marquee matchup of the season by far
probably the most important regular
season game in the nfl in years very
very basic question jeff did it live up
to the hype
you know what i if i have to give you a
yes or no answer i'm going to say yes
i'm going to say yes i think i think
because of the way it ended it was close
i've heard some people blast the
broadcast the brady love fest it's
enough already it's annoying
you thought that was a brainy love fest
i thought it was a belichick love
festival i i mean it was constantly
constantly supporting him and creating
this alibi for him if they were to lose
and don't forget his great record i
didn't think it was a love fest for
brady i mean the facts spoke for
themselves he set an all-time nfl record
goes into his old house has more wins in
that stadium this year than the patriots
it was antonio brown's old house also he
didn't get anything oh you know damn
well that has nothing to do with the
house that gronk oh boy i wish gronk was
if gronk was there
used him last night he needed them but
honestly any game living up to the hype
the real answer is probably i'll i'll
take it back is no but i thought it did
a pretty good job i thought it was
engaging for week four of a 17 week
season it was a pretty good game and
also it was a great chess match oh you
know you know who was the real winner
man the coming out party for my boy max
jones mac jones looked damn good boy
looked a-okay i think the future is
bright up in massachusetts man yeah i
mean he's he's got talent he's got some
ability there's no question about it i
mean what 18 completions in a row
you could tell that they keep a really
short leash with him
they're not gonna let i mean not even
going for it on fourth down when they
needed a few yards at the end of the
game to make that a shorter field goal
in the rain well he's in horrible
conditions
if you build your future on a rookie
quarterback and you get rid of tom brady
in the process you should be able to
expect three yards
three yards how many how many times did
how many times did tom brady throw 30
passes his rookie year with bill
belichick how many times it was a
totally different game 20 years ago the
nfl isn't even close to being what it is
now as far as how many times i don't
know and it doesn't matter because the
offense is so much different now that's
true i'll give you that yeah here's my
thought on it i don't think it lived i
thought the pre-game lived up to the
height i thought it was a great end of
the game you know the game was a little
slow in the middle of it it wasn't great
but
brady was off whether he was mentally
affected by going back there and
everything that where he went up against
the greatest defensive schemer in the
history of the nfl i think he would have
to throw what stephen belichick his son
we'll talk about him in a second too
that was unbelievable by the way to be
consistent here one of the greatest
answers ever by the way jeff greatest
answers in
post-game press conference history what
was the light going against tom brady i
want to be against tom brady every day
in defense oh timeout he said it way
more defensively than that that was one
of his most annoying comments did you
hear the comments
we want a good tom brady practice every
day
this guy's amazing i don't hate him but
just because i'm not reading his bio and
singing praises about him constantly you
guys get mad at me like i'm not allowed
to use it
out here no no allegedly brady i mean
belichick went through some probably
secret tunnel in the in foxborough
stadium and he met with brady for 20
minutes after the game just closed doors
right because the narrative everybody
wants to pit these two against each
other they hate each other you know
belichick's gotta gotta redeem himself
dude i've got a couple friends that were
in the in the the patriots organization
they tell they told me that bill
belichick behind closed doors is a cool
dude funny dude awesome guy
who he is in front of the media is who
he is who he is you know for the world
to see
i respect that about him i respect that
the whole world doesn't get to know
everything about everybody you know who
i am inside the locker room is who i am
inside the locker room who i am outside
of it is somebody completely different
not everybody gets to be a part of it
not everybody truly is true
but when you choose not to expose any
other part of your personality ever
then all we can judge is what we see and
what you choose to project so i don't
think it's out of the realm of
possibility that we could be critical of
bill belichick every now and then
hey thanks so much for checking out that
short clip from sports now with tom
zenner if you want to see another short
clip click right here or if you want to
see the entire episode click right here
thanks for watching everybody
[Music]